ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALEY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL- MERIMBULA.
BARRICADE HAND BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BURKE CALDERON CORREO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA FONG ASURE
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA. MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA WHEN
O'DONNELL ANDERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO C. R. TO SMITH. STONE
BEING RELATIVE ERRORS VIA FOOD
RAW. VOEPEL WALDRON BOARD WHEN
WICKS WOULD MISTER SEA.
MEMBERS
OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN. IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YES SIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. I'M NOT A
GOOD. WE PRAY TO YOU TODAY BY
STANDING HERE ON THIS ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. BOWING OUR HEADS AND
TURNING OUR HEARTS TOWARDS YOU.
SEEKING YOUR BLESSINGS THAT YOU
BLESS US IN OUR ENDEAVORS. TO
SERVE YOU THROUGH REPRESENTING
ALL THOSE THAT ARE FACING
INJUSTICE. BY STANDING UP AND
BEING VOCAL. ALLOW US TO REMAIN
GROUNDED IN THE VALUES THAT ARE
MOST PLEASING TO YOU. USE US TO
BRING HOPE TO THOSE THAT NEEDED
TO. IN OUR GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I MEAN. THANK YOU
MA'AM YES SIR. YES I GUESS IT
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
STONE. NUMBER I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. ISRAEL
OR- THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY JIMMY
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY APRIL
FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
A METHOD SEVEN AM YAMAZAKI-
WHEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FORTY
FOURTH DISTRICT IS ADDING SHE
FOLKS REPORT THAT THIS
REFLECTIVITY ON. FOLLOWING
REPLACED ON THE MORNING ROLL
CALL SEVENTY FOUR AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BALCONY HAND BEEN IT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
MISTER RAMOS MOVES AND. MISTER
FLORA SECONDS. AT THE READING
OF PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK.
WHO TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. MS
REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHT TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SMITH TO HAVE HIS SPELL SEATED
AT HIS DESK. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AND RAMOS
TO SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM NINETY EIGHT EIGHTY
pFROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLACE
IT ON THE INACTIVE FILE. LOCAL
NOTE. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW AB EIGHT
ONE ONE THREE OF US FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
ORDER THE BILL TO THE SECOND
READING FILE THE BILL IS NOT
FISCAL AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US. WE HAVE A SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION
MEMBERS. THANK YOU TO MY FELLOW
GUESTS A 18% OR PRINTERS IT MY
BEAUTIFUL WIFE MARGARET SMITH.
TO COME AND VISIT US TO SEE
WHAT WE DO ON THE FLOOR AND SHE
IS AT ALL. ESPECIALLY WITH THE
GREEN CARPET AND I WOULD DO
WITH IT LIKE ALL OF YOU TO
RECOGNIZE MY WIFE THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS SHE'S A- PUT UP WITH ME.
AND IS OF ALL OF YOU KNOW AS A
MAN. ALL YOU HAVE TO SAY IS YES
DEAR AND YOU'LL BE OKAY. THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING. THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO
1-494-153-2379 1-432-700-1280
ONE FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN SIX
EIGHTY WITH THEM IT'S EXCITING
ARE WITH WOMEN'S CENTER TO
SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS LEVINSON
OF THE MEMBERS FIVE SEVENTY ONE
WITH A MINUTE SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN OF THE MEMBERS NINETY
NINE WITH A MINUTES THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT OF THE MEMBERS
FIFTEEN NINETY TWO SIXTY ONE OF
THE MEMBERS. FOR FIFTY FOUR
FIVE TWENTY THREE FOR THE
MINUTES. FOR THE FOR THE MOST
PART WE- OF THE MEMBERS HAVE
FIFTY EIGHT. TO MEMBERS FOR.
FIVE OF THEM. FIFTEEN WITH. SIX
ONE. EIGHT WITH A MEMBER.
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN. SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WITH A MEMBER
IT'S NINE TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
NINE OF THE MINUTES
1-591-428-1540 SIX FIFTY NINETY
SIX THIRTY FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN. FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE WITH
A MINUTES ONE OF SIX OF THE
MERITS AND ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FIFTEEN WITH A MEMBERS. ALL
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. FILE ITEMS.
THIRTY SEVEN. THROUGH. FIFTY
SIX. PASS AND RETAIN WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY. ON
FILE ITEM. FIFTY SEVEN. WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM FIFTY
EIGHT. THIS IS AB. FOUR SIXTY
FIVE. BYE MISTER NAZARIAN. THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SIXTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER THIS AREA IN AN ACT
RELATING TO PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS. MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE
BEGUN BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE PLEASE THE RETENTION
MISTER NAZARIAN MISTER NAZARIAN
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES TODAY
AND TODAY I'M PRESENTING A
BEFORE SIXTY FIVE THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARIES RECEIVE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY TRAINING FOR SERVING
PATIENTS IN L. G. B. T. Q. Y.
PLUS RELIGIOUS AND ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES. PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARIES PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES TO SENIORS AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES. THE
MANAGEMENT IS FOR CLIENTS
INCLUDING DAILY CARE HOUSING
MEDICAL NEEDS. UNFORTUNATELY
MANY SENIORS IN THE L. G. . T.
Q. I COMMUNITY FACE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES AS THEY AGE AND ARE
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION IN OUR SOCIETY-
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE IS
INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT THE
LGBTQI COMMUNITY RELIGIOUS AND
ETHNIC SENIORS. GET COMPETENT
AND RESPECTFUL CARE BY THEIR
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS. THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE
CLERK WILL. CLOTHES ARE ALL
TIED UP I SIXTY NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEMS FIFTY NINE. THROUGH.
SIXTY THREE. PRINCESSA FILE
ITEM. SIXTY FOUR. THIS IS AB
TEN THIRTY NINE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY NINE
BY SIMPLY MEMBER WHEN AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION THIS WHEN
YOU MAIL OPEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT AB ONE ZERO THREE
NINE WHICH WILL EXTEND THE
SUNSET DATE THERE REQUIRES THE
BOARD OF EDUCATION TO ADOPT A
MODEL CURRICULUM RELATIVE TO
THE VIETNAMESE AMERICAN.
REFUGEE PROMOTED GENOCIDE AND
AMONG COMMUNITY EXPERIENCES.
WHEN I WAS IN THE SENATE MY
BILL SB EIGHT NINE FIVE WHICH
CREATED THIS REQUIREMENT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY AND WAS SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR. DURING THAT TIME
MANY COMMUNITY GROUPS FOR MY
DISTRICT AND ACROSS THE STATE
CAME TOGETHER IN SUPPORT OF
CRANE THIS CURRICULUM. MORE
THAN ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE TRAVEL
TO SACRAMENTO TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT. FOR SB EIGHT NINE FIVE
DO COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND MORE
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND. SIGN A
PETITION OF SUPPORT MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUAL HAS NEVER BEEN
TO THIS TO THE SACRAMENTO YET
ALONE TO THE CAPITAL AND TO
EVEN TESTIFY. THE TRAVEL HOURS
ON BUSES CARS AND SOME FLEW IN
FROM OUT OF STATE FOR THAT I AM
VERY GRATEFUL. FOR THEIR
SUPPORT DEDICATION AND
DETERMINATION TO HELP PASS SB.
EIGHT NINE FIVE. SB EIGHT NINE
FIVE NOW AB ONE ZERO THREE NINE
THIS YEAR WAS CREATED ORDER FOR
OUR CHILDREN TO LEARN ABOUT
THESE IMPORTANT MOMENTS IN OUR
HISTORY. REALLY RELATED TO THE
VIDEO MISS AMERICAN REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE INCLUDING THE FALL
OF SAIGON NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. THESE REFUGEES GAVE UP
EVERYTHING IN ORDER TO GAIN
THEIR FREEDOM AND THE STORIES
TOLD BY BELLAMY'S AMERICAN
REFUGEES VIMY SPOKE PEOPLE AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE REPUBLIC OF
VIETNAM ARMED FORCES. ARE
PORTED FOR CHILDREN TODAY TO
LEARN ABOUT. SOUTHEAST ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNICANT POSE THE
LARGEST REFUGEE COMMUNITY EVER
TO BE RISOTTO UNITED STATES.
AND NOW THAT NUMBER IS WELL
OVER THREE MILLION IN THE
COUNTRY AND OVER MILLION
CALLING CALIFORNIA HOME. AS THE
AUTHOR OF AB TEN THIRTY NINE
BUT MORE IMPORTANT AS A VIDEO
MAYES REFUGEE MYSELF. I AM
PROUD AND GRATEFUL THAT MY
COLLEAGUES. RECOGNIZE THE
INHERENT VALUE IN EDUCATIONAL
MERITS OF THIS BILL WHEN IT WAS
FIRST INTRODUCED AS DEAL. TO DO
TODAY. WE ARE PAVING THE WAY
FOR OCHO TO THE LEARN THE
STORIES OF SOME OF MANY SOUTH
VIETNAMESE FAMILIES. WHO RISK
THEIR LIVES AND THE LIVES OF
THEIR FAMILIES TO ESCAPE THE
CONNORS RHEGIUM. THE SYSTEMATIC
PROSECUTION AND KILLING OF
CAMBODIANS DURING THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE. AND THE STORIES IN
HISTORY THE MONK COMMUNITY TO
JOIN THE UNITED STATES MILITARY
IN LAOS TO FIGHT FOR FREEDOM.
THIS MODEL CURRICULUM WILL
TEACH OUR CHILDREN. THE STORIES
OF REFUGEES WHO FACE ALL ODDS
TO REGAIN THEIR FREEDOM.
LESSONS THAT NEED TO BE TAUGHT
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND NOT
FORGOTTEN. THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED A UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR WHEN MR
O'DONNELL. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN THIRTY NINE. MY
COMMUNITY OF LONG BEACH IS
KNOWN AROUND THE WORLD IS HOME
TO THE LARGEST CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY OUTSIDE. OF CAMBODIA.
MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMUNITY CAME TO THIS COUNTRY
FILLING ONE OF THE GREATEST
ATROCITIES OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY. NEARLY TWENTY MILLION
PEOPLE DIED UNDER THE EXTREMIST
RULE OF THE COMMUTER ROUTES
THROUGH THE RUTHLESS AGENDA OF
FORCED LABOR THOUGHT CONTROL
AND MASS EXECUTION. AB TEN
THIRTY NINE WILL HELP ENSURE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS UNDERSTAND
THE CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE AND
OTHER EVENTS THAT LED MANY
SOUTHEAST ASIANS TO SEEK REFUGE
HERE. IN THE UNITED STATES I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
TIRELESS WORK TO EDUCATE ALL
CALIFORNIANS ON THE HISTORY AND
IMPORTANCE OF REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES IN THE UNITED
STATES LIKE THE ONE I AM
PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT. IN
LONG BEACH. I STRONGLY URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
DONNA MISTER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE AS A
PROUD JOIN AUTHOR OF AB TEN
THIRTY NINE AND I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER MANY YEARS
IN LEADING THIS JOURNEY TO
ENSURE THAT THE THAT. THE
EXPERIENCES. OF REFUGEES OF THE
AS SHE CORRECTLY INDICATED THE
LARGEST. OF THE LARGEST
REFUGEES TO COME TO THIS
COUNTRY DURING A OF A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME. OF THE THIRTY
THAT THEIR EXPERIENCES ARE
RECOGNIZED AS SOMEONE WHO
REPRESENTS. THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE WHICH HAS THE LARGEST GOOD
MUSIC COMMUNITY. OF ANY SINGLE
CITY OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM- THERE
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT THESE
EXPERIENCES ARE NOT JUST
SOMETHING THAT'S RELEVANT. TO
THE VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY OR IN
THIS CASE AS WE FURTHER. EXPAND
THE EDUCATION THE REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE TO THE CAMBODIAN
AMONG COMMUNITY ALL OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND OTHER SOUTHEAST
ASIAN COMMUNITIES THAT ARRIVED
AS REFUGEES THEIR EXPERIENCES
ARE NOT JUST REBEL RELEVANT FOR
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES. THEIR
EXPERIENCE OR RELEVANT EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF US IS CALIFORNIANS
AND AMERICANS. AND THEIR
EXPERIENCES. THEIR HISTORY
NEEDS TO BE TAUGHT AS SUCH. AND
SO I'M PROUD TO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY NINE.
I WANT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM GARDEN GROVE FOR
CONTINUING TO PUSH ON THIS
ISSUE AGAIN FOR MANY YEARS AND
I KNOW THAT. WE WILL GET TO A
PLACE WHERE THE HISTORY IS NOT
ONLY RECOGNIZED BUT THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY TAKE ACTIONS TO UP. TO
HELP TO MITIGATE SO MUCH. OF
THE PAIN THAT IS BECAUSE THANK
YOU. THANK KALRA MISS COOL IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I'M VERY
HONORED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MAJOR. AFTER THE FALL OF
VIETNAM HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WE SAW A LARGE
POPULATION OF PEOPLE. FROM
VIETNAM WHO MOVED IN THE COUNTY
THE CHURCH BUILDING WHERE MY
SON IS THE SENIOR PASTOR SHARE
THAT FACILITY WITH VIETNAMESE
REFUGEES WHO DID THEIR OWN
WORSHIP PROGRAM DURING THE DAY.
AND WAS EVENTUALLY BUILT WITH
THEIR ASSISTANCE SO THERE ARE
VERY INVESTED IN THE COMMITTEE
RANCHO CORDOVA IN THE SOUTH OF
THE REGION. AND THEN MORE TO
THE POINT MY GRAND SON BEN WHO
TURNS SEVEN THIS YEAR- IS A
YOUNG MAN THAT CAME OUT OF
SEVERAL COUNTIES FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. THEN AS OF LONG
HERITAGE YEARS IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL SO THIS BILL IS DIRECTLY
RELEVANT TO THE TYPE OF
EDUCATION AT PENN WILL GET IS A
GROSS. AND I'M VERY HONORED TO
SUPPORT IT I THANK YOU MY
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SENATOR RAND FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS COOLEY I SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM IS AND WHEN YOU MAY
CLOSE I'VE JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. WITHOUT
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
HEY. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY NINE OH
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM SIXTY FIVE. IS AB TEN
SIXTY FIVE BY MR MENTION
CORKERY SOMERVILLE TEN SIXTY
FIVE BY SIN REMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN ANAK LIVING IN
TAXATION OF MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION- FOR. MR
MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TEN
SIXTY FIVE CRATES THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS PREVENTION
VOLUNTARY TAX CONTRIBUTION
BONTA. AND ALLOWS TAXPAYERS TO
MAKE VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS ON
THE CALIFORNIA TAX RETURNS THIS
PROGRAM IS A NATIONAL MODEL FOR
COMMUNITY POLICING THAT BRINGS
TOGETHER LAW ENFORCEMENT MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS. AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
IMPROVE LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
RESPONSE TO THOSE EXPERIENCING
A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AS
DONATIONS WERE RECEIVED WOULD
HELP THE CRISIS INTERVENTION
TEAMS PROGRAM OPERATED BY NAOMI.
THIS PROGRAM GIVES OFFICERS
IMPORTANT TOOLS TO PERFORM
THEIR JOB SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY WHILE HELPING TO
KEEP PEOPLE LIVING WITH A
MENTAL ILLNESS OUT OF JAIL OFF
THE STREETS AND ROLLED INTO
TREATMENT AND ON THE ROAD TO
RECOVERY. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
ABOUT. I THINK IT WAS
MAIENSCHEIN. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. I CALL
THE ROLL. IT IS AT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF A. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT. CLARK WELL. CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE ABOUT EYES SIXTY EIGHT. NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX.
FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB THREE
NINETY BY MR BERMAN. AND THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NINETY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS REGULATION. MR BERMAN.
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES HAVE YOU EVER TRIED
TO CANCEL SERVICE ONLINE ONLY
TO BE CONFRONTED WITH AN
INCONVENIENCE CONFUSING TIME
CONSUMING PROCESS THAT SEEMS
DESIGNED TO GET YOU TO GIVE UP
AND KEEP PAYING OR SIGN UP FOR
FREE TRIAL OR FOR A
SUBSCRIPTION AT A PROMOTIONAL
PRICE ONLY TO FORGET AND LATER
BE CHARGED FULL PRICE FOR A
PRODUCT OR SERVICE YOU DON'T
REALLY WANT OR NEED. AB THREE
NINETY WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CONSUMERS TO CANCEL THEIR
SUBSCRIPTIONS ONLINE WITHOUT
HAVING TO JUMP THROUGH HOOPS
AND WILL IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY
FOR CONSUMERS ABOUT WHEN AND
HOW MUCH THEIR CHARGE FOR
SUBSCRIPTIONS THESE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOLLOWING THE
EXPLOSION OF FREE TRIALS AND
PROMOTIONS IN RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC ANOTHER TIME WHEN MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE LOOKING FOR.
WAYS TO SAVE MONEY TO PAY RENT
AND PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE AB
THREE NINETY PASSED OUT OF
COMMITTEE WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND A FEW
EXTRA CO AUTHORS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. I THINK
IT WAS BERMAN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION. MORE DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CARCLUB THE ROLE. THESE
ARE NOT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF. IS THAT A
VOTE. YEAH. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT THROUGH
SEVENTY EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM. SEVENTY NINE. BUT I
MISSED IRWIN THIS IS FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY NINE AB SEVEN FIFTY ONE
THE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN FIFTY ONE BY SIN REMEMBER
IRWIN AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING THE VITAL RECORDS
MISSOURI EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT AB SEVEN FIVE ONE WHICH
HAD UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN HEALTH AND
APPROPRIATIONS THIS BILL WILL
PERMANENTLY AUTHORIZED COUNTY
RECORDER'S WITH SEPT ELECTRONIC
RECORDS REQUEST ACCESS
CERTIFIED VITAL RECORDS WHICH
ARE BIRTH MARRIAGE AND DEATH
CERTIFICATES. CURRENTLY TWENTY
FIVE COUNTIES USE REMOTE
IDENTITY PROOFING TO PROCESS
THESE REQUESTS INCLUDING MY
HOME COUNTY VENTURA COUNTY IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE MAINTAIN
SAFE CONVENIENT ACCESS TO VITAL
RECORDS WHICH ARE OFTEN.
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN BENEFITS
SERVICES OR INSURANCE TO ENSURE
SECURITY OF THESE RECORDS AB
SEVEN FIVE ONE UPDATES THE
STATUE TO ADHERETO THE GOLD
STANDARD OF INFORMATION
SECURITY. THE NEXT STANDARD
WHICH IS THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF STANDARDS AND TECHNOLOGY
WHICH IS ROUTINELY CITED AND
USED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY BY
REVISING THE CODE TO REFLECT
THIS STANDARDS AB SEVEN FIVE
ONE FOLLOWS THE PRACTICE OF.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS A
PROVIDES IMPORTANT FLEXIBILITY
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
LAW ALLOWING FOR ALTERNATIVE
TYPES OF VERIFICATION TO BE
USED INCREASING ACCESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY NOT HAVE A
GOVERNMENT. ISSUED ID OR
UTILITY ACCOUNT WITH THE
PROGRAM SUNSETTING THIS YEAR WE
NEED TO TAKE LEGISLATIVE ACTION
NOW OR CALIFORNIANS WILL LOSE
THEIR ABILITY TO REQUEST COPIES
OF VITAL RECORDS ONLINE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR WENT. SAYING NO MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THIS
ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL. SEVERAL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR
PASS AND RETAIN FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FIVE. IS AB TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY MISTER
NAZARIAN CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SIMPLY BERMAN THIS AREA AN
ACTOR LIVING IN HEALING ARTS
MISTER NAZARIAN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
AB TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS
RECEIVE PAYMENTS FROM A DRUG OR
DEVICE COMPANY TO DISCLOSE
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS IN WRITING
TO EACH PATIENT PRIOR TO
TREATMENT. THE DISCLOSURE WOULD
REQUIRE A LINK TO THE ALREADY
EXISTING FEDERAL OPEN PAYMENTS
WEBSITE AND A PATIENT SIGNATURE
OPEN PAYMENTS IS THE EASY TO
USE FEDERAL WEBSITE WHICH LISTS
FINANCIAL EXCHANGES BETWEEN
DRUG AND DEVICE MANUFACTURERS
AND HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. AND
IT BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN COLLEAGUES I BRING
THIS BILL FORWARD BECAUSE A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE WHO HAD
TESTED POSITIVE WHO HAD TESTED
FOR THE BRCA. GENE AND IT SEEMS
THAT CANCER MIGHT BE EMINENT
FOR HER- DECIDED TO HAVE A
DOUBLE MASTECTOMY- ONLY TO
REALIZE LATER THAT THE
PHYSICIAN THAT CONDUCTED THE
SURGERY. WAS UTILIZING NON FDA
APPROVED DEVICES THAT. MADE HER
HAVE TO GO THROUGH SIX MORE
RECONSTRUCTIVE SURGERIES
SURGERIES AND RECONSTRUCTIVE
SURGERIES TO UNDO WHAT THE
FIRST POSITION MADE MISTAKES
DOING. AND HAD SHE KNOWN ABOUT
THIS DISCLOSURE SIMPLE SUNSHINE
BILL. TAKING HER TO THE WEBSITE
WAIT SHE WOULD LEARN ABOUT THE
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS IN
PAYMENTS THAT SURGEON HAD
RECEIVED FROM THAT DEVICE
COMPANY. SHE WOULD HAVE ASKED
MORE QUESTIONS AND NOT HAVE TO
GO THROUGH SIX SURGERIES SO I
BRING THIS BILL FORWARD HUMBLY
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE CONTINUE
STRENGTHENING OUR DISCLOSURES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEASURES
AREA. SAYING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS
SEVEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX A.
B. FOURTEEN OH THREE BY MR
LEVINE CARBERY. ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTINO THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE AN ACCOLADE TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN THE CLEARLY YEARS
ZERO EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MR
LEVINE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
EARLIER TODAY GOVERNOR NEWSOM
DECLARED THE WEEK OF MAY SECOND
WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS WEEK AB
FORTINO THREE WILL PUT TEETH IN
OUR PREPAREDNESS EFFORTS. BY
GIVING A GOVERNOR AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EXPLICIT AUTHORITY
TO DECLARE A STATE OR LOCAL
EMERGENCY RESULTING FROM A
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
EVENT AND ALLOW THEM TO PRE
DEPLOY RESOURCES AS NECESSARY
TO PROTECT HEALTH. SAFETY AND
PROPERTY OF RESIDENTS ACROSS
THE GOLDEN STATE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR LEVINE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM CLICK LIBERAL.
THIS DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS ARE SAID ABOUT THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON THE URGENCY.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ON THE URGENCY AS FIFTY SEVEN
NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE. THAT
BILL PASSES FILE ITEMS EIGHTY
SEVEN. THROUGH NINETY ONE. PASS
AND RETAIN FILE ITEM NINETY TWO
IS AB THREE THREE FIVE
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND OTHERS AN
ACT RELATING TO PRIVACY MS
BURNETTE HARBATH YES MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THREE THIRTY
FIVE ALLOWS MANUFACTURERS OF
RECREATIONAL BOATS AND MARINE
ENGINES TO RECEIVE HER RETRAIN
SPECIFIC CONTACT INFORMATION
FOR BUYERS OF ITS PRODUCTS FOR
THE LIMITED AND EXCLUSIVE USE
OF CONDUCTING PRODUCT SAFETY
RECALLS AND WARRANTY
VERIFICATION UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY
ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN A
PROPOSITION TWENTY FOUR.
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS IN
TWENTY TWENTY IT ESTABLISH THE
CONSUMER PRIVACY AND PERSONAL
DATA PROTECTION MEASURES AMONG
THE CENTRAL PROVISIONS OF THESE
LANDMARK LAWS IS THE RIGHT OF
CONSUMERS TO REQUEST THE
DELETION OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION OR OPT OUT OF DATA
COLLECTION AND TO REQUIRE
BUSINESSES TO COMPLY WITH SUCH
REQUESTS. A DIFFERENT PARTIES
OF EVALUATING IMPLEMENTATION OF
CONSUMER PRIVACY LAWS INSTANCES
OF EMERGE MORE CLARIFICATION IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
BUSINESSES CAN MAINTAIN.
CONSUMER DATA TO PROTECT
CONSUMER SAFETY BY RECALLING
AND REPAIRING DEFECTIVE
PRODUCTS. ONE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES INVOLVED WARRANTY
AND WE RECALL REPAIRS WHICH
REQUIRE SHARING OF CONSUMER
DATA BETWEEN THE DEALER AND THE
MANUFACTURER OF A PRODUCT.
CURRENTLY THE BOAT AND MARINE
ENGINE DEALERS AND THE BUYERS
CONTACT INFORMATION TO THE
PRODUCTS MANUFACTURER.
MANUFACTURERS USE THIS
INFORMATION TO VERIFY WARRANTY
ELIGIBILITY AND TO CONDUCT
SAFETY RECALLS DEALERS USE THIS
DATA TO VERIFY THE PRODUCT
pPOINT OF REPAIR. AB THREE
THIRTY FIVE WILL PROVIDE NAMES
SUCH S THE LEGAL CERTAINTY
THEY NEED TO COLLECT AND RETAIN
THIS INFORMATION TO USE THAT TO
PERFORM SAFETY RECALLS WILL
BENEFITING CONSUMERS TO
PURCHASE THESE PRODUCTS. WITH
THE LIMITED USE OF DATA WE
DON'T WANT TO BLOW BOTH
EXPLODING OFF THE COAST BY
ALLOWING THIS LIMITING SHARING
OF INFORMATION CONSUMERS TO BUY
PRODUCTS SUCH AS VESSELS AND
MARINE ENGINES. WILL RECEIVE
IMPORTANT TIMELY SAFETY RECALL
INFORMATION AND EASILY CONFIRM
WARRANTY VERIFICATION EIGHTY
THREE THIRTY FIVE WITH
SPECIFICALLY NOT ALTHOUGH THE
USE OF THIS INFORMATION FOR ANY
OTHER PURPOSE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU IS PEARL. C. NOTIFICATION
ON THE ITEM BURKE LIBERAL.
MEMBERS. IT IS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS IN
FILER THIS IS FILE ITEM NINETY
THREE ACR SEVENTY EIGHT.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO SENIOR
MALNUTRITION AWARENESS DAY MR
GARCIA YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE TO PRESENT ACR SEVENTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD DESIGNATE MAY
FOURTH AS SENIOR MALNUTRITION
AWARENESS DAY LEADING HEALTH
EXPERTS AGREE THAT NUTRITION
STATUS IS DIRECTLY LINKED TO
PATIENTS HEALTH AND GOOD
ATTRITION CAN KEEP OLDER ADULTS
HEALTHY AND OUT OF HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES ACCORDING TO THE
ACADEMY OF NUTRITION AND
DIETITIANS UP TO ONE OUT OF TWO
OLDER. ADULTS IS EITHER
MALNOURISHED OR AT RISK OF
BECOMING NUMBERS THIS
RESOLUTION FALLS WITHIN THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING GOAL
NUMBER FIVE WHICH STATES THAT
MANY SENIORS CANNOT AFFORD
HEALTHY FOOD DUE TO THEIR
LIMITED INCOME ACR SEVENTY
EIGHT IS THE FIRST STEP TO
RAISING MALNUTRITION AWARENESS
BY IMMEDIATELY TAKING THIS TYPE
OF STEP TO PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
INFORMATION EDUCATION ON THE
ISSUE AS WELL AS BEGIN
PROVIDING THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO OUR SENIOR
CITIZENS I ASSET THE FIRST ROLE
BE HELD OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR GARCIA. CA
NO DISCUSSION OF A ON THE
RESOLUTION THE AUTHORS ASKING
THAT THE- FIRST ROLE. BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS. SEVERAL OF THE
ROLE- AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSER ROLE THERE SEVENTY TWO
CO AUTHORS ADDING WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
PHONE. ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OUR OBSERVANCE IN HONOR OF
SECOND OF MY WEEK AND THE
LATINO SPIRIT AWARDS MISTER
RIVAS ARE YOU READY TO PROCEED
ON FILE ITEM NINETY FOUR. I AM
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND-
OPERATE ON. HOUSE RESOLUTION
THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS RELATIVE TO SINGLE
TOMORROW WEEK MYSTERY THIS YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND- COLLEAGUES YOUR AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. AND
THE PROUD SON OF MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS. IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
ON THIS FLOOR OF THIS AFTERNOON
TO RECOGNIZE SINGLE TAMAYO. A
DAY OF CELEBRATION FOR MILLIONS
OF MEXICAN AMERICANS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THROUGHOUT OUR
COUNTRY. SICK OF THE MILE HAS
BECOME A DAY WHEN WE CELEBRATE
OUR CULTURE. MARGARET'S ARE
DEEP DEEP CUTS THE
DETERMINATION AND OUR VAST
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO THE AMERICAN
WAY OF LIFE. HISTORICALLY THIS
DAY IS CELEBRATED TO
MEMORIALIZE MEXICO'S MONUMENTAL
VICTORY OVER THE FRENCH IN THE
TOWN OF PUEBLA. IT WAS A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE YEARS
AGO ON MAY FIFTH. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY TWO. UNDER THE LEADERSHIP
OF GENERAL IGNACIO ZARAGOZA. IT
MEXICAN FORCES VASTLY
OUTNUMBERED AND ILL EQUIPPED
WHEN COMPARED TO THE EIGHT
THOUSAND STRONG FRENCH ARMY.
LAUNCHED A DESPERATE EFFORT TO
DEFEND THEIR HOMELAND. AT THAT
TIME OF THE BATTLE PUEBLA THE
FRENCH ARMY WAS CONSIDERED ONE
OF THE BEST IN THE WORLD.
AGAINST ALL ODDS. AGAIN
THROUGH. PURE GRIT. THE
DETERMINATION AND LOVE OF
COUNTRY. THE MEXICAN FORCES
THEY DEFEATED THE FRENCH IT WAS
A DEFEAT THAT SENT SHOCKWAVES
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. THE
VICTORY HELPED UNIFY MEXICO IT
SPARKED AN ERA OF NATIONAL
PATRIOTISM THAT CONTINUES TO
THIS DAY. ON EVERY SINGLE THE
MILE. WE CONTINUE TO CELEBRATE
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE BRAVE
MEXICANS WHO WHO FOUGHT TO
PROTECT THEIR COUNTRY ON THAT
HISTORIC DAY IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY
TWO. AND WE ALSO CELEBRATE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF CULTURE OF THE
OVER FIFTEEN MILLION LATINOS TO
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME. LATINOS
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE CHALLENGED
THE FRONTIERS OF SOCIAL
ECONOMIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. AND HAVE STRAIGHTEN IT
UP LIFTED OUR STATE IN
COUNTLESS WAYS. SINCE THE
AMERICAN CIVIL WAR LATINOS HAVE
SERVED AND THEY CONTINUE TO
SERVE IN THE UNITED STATES
ARMED FORCES. TO SUPPORT AND
FIGHT FOR FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY
RISKING THEIR LIVES TO DEFEND
OUR COUNTRY. INDEED LATINOS IN
THE STATE HAVE EXCELLED AND LED
THE WAY IN VIRTUALLY EVERY
FIELD FROM SSR CHAVEZ AND
DOLORES HUERTA. ADVOCATING FOR
THE RIGHTS OF FARMWORKERS. THE
ALLEN- CHILL OF THE FIRST
LATINA ASTRONAUT. TO GO TO
SPACE. TO CARLOS SANTANA WHOSE
MUSICAL MASTERY HAS CAPTIVATED
THE WORLD FOR FIFTY YEARS. TO
ANTONIO NERI THE PRESIDENT CEO
OF HEWLETT PACKARD ENTERPRISES
TO OUR STATE'S FIRST LATINO
UNITED STATES SENATOR. ALEX BY
THE. BUT IT'S NOT JUST THESE
WELL KNOWN NAMES THAT ARE
LATINO HEROES TO CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME. OUR GREATEST
HEROES OFTEN GO UNRECOGNIZED.
ESPECIALLY THE FLAG THIS LAST
YEAR AMID THE THIS HISTORIC
PANDEMIC. IT WAS HARD WORKING
AND LET THE- ESSENTIAL WORKERS
FROM FARMWORKERS FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS TO FRONTLINE HEALTHCARE
AND EMERGENCY RESPONDERS. WHO
STEPPED UP. AMID THIS PANDEMIC
TO KEEP OUR STATE RUNNING TO
KEEP PEOPLE FED AND TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER. WITH
THEIR HELP WE BECAME A MODEL
CALIFORNIA BECAME A MODEL FOR
THE REST OF THE NATION. AND ON
THIS SEQUEL TO MILE. LET US
HONOR OUR ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
LET US CELEBRATE THE GREAT
STRENGTH OF OUR DIVERSE CITY.
IN SPIRIT OF RECOGNIZING ON
GOING LET THE- CONTRIBUTIONS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
LATINO CAUCUS IS PROUD TO
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY ARLECCHINO
SPIRIT AWARD HONOREES WILL BE
SELECTED FOR THEIR OUTSTANDING
ACHIEVEMENTS AND CONTRIBUTIONS
TO OUR STATE. TO OUR COUNTRY
AND TO THE WORLD. IN A MINUTE
HE CLERK WILL READ THEIR NAMES
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WHICH RANGE
FROM THE FIELDS OF MEDICINE TO
LITERATURE. TO ADVOCACY THE
JOURNALIST TO SOME. GEN SOME-
THE JOURNALISM TO BUSINESS INTO
THE ARTS EACH OF THIS YEAR'S
NINE HONOREES SHOULD GIVE US
ALL HOPE. FOR THE FUTURE OF OUR
STATE. I KNOW THAT WITH LEADERS
LIKE THESE WE ARE IN GOOD HANDS
AND WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON HOUSE
RESOLUTION THIRTY SIX THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MYSTERY OF US. ISRAEL'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER HAD MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF HR THIRTY SIX.
SINGLE TO MY WEEK. THIS MOMENT
IN MEXICAN HISTORY SHOWS THE
POWER OF THE PEOPLE WHEN UNITED
AGAINST AN OPPRESSOR. WHEN THE
FRENCH CAME TO INVADE MEXICO
THEY HAD ALL THE TOOLS AND THE
TRAINING. BUT THEY DID NOT HAVE
THE CORNERSTONE. IN HONOR OF
THIS EVENT I WOULD LIKE TO
QUOTE A FEMALE LEADER AUTHOR
HERO TO CHILDREN AND TEACHER OF
TEACHERS FROM MY DISTRICT. DR
LILY RIVERA. PERMISSION TO READ.
WITHOUT OBJECTION IN HER
ARTICLE ABOUT THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF SYNC WITH THE MY- DOCTOR TO
THAT UP RIGHTS. IT IS NOT ABOUT
CELEBRATING A VICTORY IN A
BATTLE ON THE FIFTH OF MAY IN
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO. IN THE CITY
OF PUEBLA IN THE COUNTRY OF
MEXICO. IT'S NOT ABOUT HONORING
POOR AND UNTRAINED PEASANTS.
WHO THREW FOR THE- FAR
OUTNUMBERED DEFEATED SOLDIERS
FROM WHAT WAS THEN THE GREATEST
MILITARY FORCE. IN THE WORLD
THE FRENCH ARMY. WE CELEBRATE
THE SINGLE TOMORROW NOT IN
RECOGNITION OF THE BATTLE AND
ANOTHER NATION BUT TO BATTLE
FOR RECOGNITION IN THIS NATION.
RECOGNITION THAT WE ARE EQUAL
TO ALL OTHERS IN X. INTELLECT
AND GOODNESS THAT WE REPRESENT
A POSITIVE ELEMENT IN AMERICAN
SOCIETY. WE SEEK RECOGNITION SO
THAT OUR CHILDREN'S POTENTIAL
WILL BE ALLOWED TO FLOURISH
THAT WE WILL BE GIVEN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY IN THE WORKFORCE
AND LEADERSHIP OF THIS NATION.
GOALS THAT TO STATISTICS
CONFIRM WE HAVE NOT YET
RECEIVED ACHIEVED. FINALLY WE
CONNECT TO A BATTLE IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR FOREFATHERS
BECAUSE WE NEED TO APPRECIATION
FOR THE CONTRIBUTION WE HAVE
MADE TO THIS COUNTRY. MEMBERS
AS WE CELEBRATE SINGLE TO MY
OWN MAY WE CELEBRATE THE
STRENGTH OF THE PEOPLE AS WELL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS REYES MISTER
ROSS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
CAUCUS MAY FIFTH CINCO DE MAYO
COMMEMORATES THE BATTLE OF
PUEBLA WHICH PITTED MEXICAN
FORCES OF PRESIDENT BENITO LAW
THIS AGAINST THE OVERWHELMING
FORCES OF THE FRENCH EMPEROR
NAPOLEON THE THIRD. AS THE
RESOLUTION STATES THE BATTLE OF
PUEBLA IS A SYMBOL OF SPIRIT
AND COURAGE IN THE FACE OF
ADVERSITY. IN THE STRUGGLE FOR
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY. HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES THE MEXICAN
VICTORY OF THAT WEBER HAS
BECOME A DAY TO CELEBRATE
MEXICAN CULTURE AND THAT TINO
CONTRIBUTIONS AND ALL FIELDS OF
ENDEAVOR. I LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTICIPATING IN THE LATINO
SPIRIT AWARDS AND TO HONOR THE
RECIPIENTS WHO DEMONSTRATE THE
SPIRIT OF THOSE AT THE BATTLE
OF PUEBLA TODAY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU MR
ROBERTS AND MR JONES SAWYER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR THIRTY
SIX I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING. FORTH
THIS RESOLUTION WHICH
RECOGNIZES MAY FIFTH A SINGLE
TAMAYO AND CELEBRATES THE
RESILIENCE OF THE MISSING
PEOPLE AND LATINO COMMUNITY
CENTER THE MAIL. DENIAL
BONNER'S THE COURAGE OF THOSE
WHO FOUGHT INVALID HE DEFEATED
TURNING AT THE BATTLE OF PUEBLA
IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO. DURING
THAT CIVIL WAR MEXICAN TROOPS
PLAYED A VITAL PIVOTAL ROLE
ALONGSIDE THE UNIONS DEFEAT OF
THE CONFEDERATE STATES AND A
BATTLE OVER SLAVERY IN THE U.
S. FROM THE AMERICAN CIVIL WAR.
BOTH WORLD WARS THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AND A
FARMWORKERS MOVEMENT LATINOS
HAVE THIRD ASSEMBLY CONTRIBUTED
TO THE IDEALS OF DEMOCRACY. AND
FREEDOM AND ARE DEEPLY
INGRAINED IN OUR AMERICAN
HISTORY. AS WE CONTINUE
CHALLENGING THE INTOLERABLE
ABUSES AGAINST THE LATINO AND
MIGRANT COMMUNITIES. LET US
ALWAYS REMEMBER WE'RE TRULY A
NATION OF IMMIGRANTS. STANDING
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AND JOINING MY
COLLEAGUES OF THE LOOK
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO CELEBRATE A COMMUNITY
KNOWN FOR RESILIENCE. LET US
RECOGNIZE OUR SHARED STRUGGLE
AND WORK IN UNITY TOWARD OUR
PEOPLE'S LIBERATION. THANK YOU
AGAIN TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
FOR I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
SUPPORT ACR FIFTY CENT. THANK
YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER MR
GABRIEL YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF HR THIRTY SIX WANT
TO THANK OUR- INCREDIBLE
CALLING FROM HOLLISTER FOR
BRING FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THE STORY OF THE
BATTLE OF PUEBLA IS ONE OF
GREAT COURAGE AND ENDURING
RESILIENCE AND A FITTING
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON THE
COURAGE CONTRIBUTIONS AND
INCREDIBLE ACHIEVEMENTS. OF THE
LATINO COMMUNITY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. EVERY YEAR
WE HONOR LEADERS AND ACTIVISTS
AND LATINO COMMUNITY FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO PUBLIC SERVICE
BUSINESS PHILANTHROPY. SCIENCE
MUSIC SPORTS CULTURE AND SO
MUCH MORE. LATINOS ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF OUR STATE'S
DNA IN CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE
THE SPECIAL PLACE IT IS TODAY.
WITHOUT THE REMARKABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR LATINO
COMMUNITY. THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
IS PROUD TO HELP RECOGNIZE OUR
LATINO BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND
OUR SOLIDARITY WITH THEM IS
BASED ON SHARED VALUES SHARED
EXPERIENCES. AND IN MANY CASES
SHARE DNA. INDEED ACCORDING TO
RECENT RESEARCH 25% OF LATINOS
HAVE SIGNIFICANT JEWISH
ANCESTRY. THIS INCLUDES OUR
VERY OWN CALLING FROM BALDWIN
PARK AND HER SISTER SENATOR
SUSAN RUBIO FOR THE DESCENDANTS
OF SPANISH CONVEY OURSELVES. IT
IS ALSO APPROPRIATE TODAY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LATINOS ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF OUR JEWISH
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA.
APPROXIMATELY 15% OF JEWS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY TRACE THEIR
ROOTS TO LATIN AMERICA. AND
LATINO JEWS HAVE MADE IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE AND
NATION. THESE INCLUDE
LUMINARIES IN GOVERNMENT LIKE
ALESSANDRA MY ARC US THE FIRST
LATINO AND FIRST IMMIGRANT TO
SERVICE SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY. WITH THE PROUD SON OF
JEWISH CUBAN REFUGEES. MEDIA
PERSONALITIES LIKE ONE OF THE
C. ON HOST DON FRANCISCO AND
ENTERTAINERS LIKE BRUNO MARS
GOOGLE IT. IN SHORT OUR JEWISH
COMMUNITY FEELS A DEEP SENSE OF
KINSHIP WITH THE LATINO
COMMUNITY AND WE ARE PROUD TO
JOIN THE LATINO CAUCUS TODAY.
IN RECOGNIZING THE IMMENSE
CONTRIBUTIONS THE LATINO CAUCUS
COMMUNITY HAS MADE TO OUR
STATE. ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE ON HR THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL. SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. THE AUTHOR MISTER
RIVAS'S ASKED THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION CARPAL OF THE
ROLE. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLARK WELL CLOSER OTHER SIXTY
SIX CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS NINETEEN YEARS AGO THE
LATINO CAUCUS CREATED THE
LATINO SPIRIT AWARDS TO
RECOGNIZE INDIVIDUALS WHO
EXEMPLIFY THE TRUE SPIRIT OF
LATINO CULTURE AND HERITAGE
TODAY WE HONOR NINE INDIVIDUALS
WHO REPRESENT A WIDE RANGE OF
TALENTS FOUND IN OUR STATE.
BECAUSE OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC OUR HONOREES ARE NOT
PRESENT BUT WE WANT TO SHARE
THEIR NAMES THE CATEGORY OF
RECOGNITION. AND SOME
BIOGRAPHICAL INFORMATION ABOUT
THEM WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
RECOGNITION OF THE LATINO
SPIRIT WARD HONOREES FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THE
CORPORATE. ON EVERY NUMBER ONE
IS JEFFREY DR JEFFREY GARCIA.
HE IS THE HONOREE FOR CHEAP
RENT AND HEALTH AND SCIENCE HE
IS A DOCTOR OF OPTOMETRY
PRACTICING IN THE MORE FOR AND
VOLUNTEERS HIS TIME AND
SERVICES TO PROVIDE CARE TO
THOSE IN THE U. S. AND ABROAD.
HONOREE NUMBER TWO IS RENOWNED
GRANDE SHE IS THE HONOREE FOR
CHEAP RENT AND LITERATURE AND
ADVOCACY. SHE IS THE AUTHOR OF-THE DISTANCE BETWEEN US HER
MEMOIR ABOUT HER LIFE BEFORE
AND AFTER ARRIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES FROM MEXICO. AND
AS AN UNDOCUMENTED CHILD
IMMIGRANTS. ON EVERY THREE IS
MARIA YOU KNOW HOSA SHE IS AN
HONOREE FOR CHEAP WRITTEN
JOURNALISM AND MEDIA. SHE IS A
PEABODY AWARD WINNING
JOURNALIST WHO COVERS ISSUES
IMPORTANT TO THE LATINO
COMMUNITY AND CIVIL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES FACING A MORE
DIVERSE AMERICA. HONOREE FOR IS
HIGH MAY BE HORRENDOUS. HE IS
THE HONOREE FOR CHIEF IN RADIO
BROADCASTING AND PHILANTHROPY.
HE IS A SPANISH LANGUAGE VOICE
OF THE LOS ANGELES DODGERS IN
THE LONGEST SERVING BROADCASTER
IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL. ON
EVERY FIVE IS CARLOS AND LINDA
LOOK READY THEY ARE THE OF THE
HONOREES FOR CHEAP RENT AND
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT. THEY
FOUNDED THE CESAR CHAVEZ CLUB
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE A CIVIC AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE ORGANIZATION
FOR YOUTH IN SAN DIEGO. HONOREE
SIX IS FRANK V. LIMA. HE IS THE
OWNER REPORT SHE'D BEEN IN
PUBLIC SERVICE. HE IS A LOS
ANGELES FIREFIGHTER AND THE
TWELFTH GENERAL SECRETARY
TREASURER OF THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF FIREFIGHTERS. ON
A RE SEVEN IS PATTY RODRIGUEZ
SHE IS THE HONOREE FOR CHEAP
RENT AND BUSINESS AND
PHILANTHROPY. SHE IS AN
ENTREPRENEUR TV PRODUCER AND
ACTIVISTS. ON A RE EIGHT IS
MARIA A CS SALAS. SHE IS THE
HONOREE FOR TREATMENT AND
PUBLIC SERVICE. SHE HAS SERVED
THE PEOPLE OF JUDAH VISTA AND
SAN DIEGO FOR DECADES. OUR LAST
HONOREE IS SIMONE SILVA. HE IS
THE HONOREE FOR CHEAP IN ARTS
HE IS AN ARTIST SPEAKER AND
AUTHOR WHO INSPIRES OTHERS TO
OVERCOME THEIR OBSTACLES.
EMBRACE THEIR INDIVIDUALITY.
AND REGAIN THEIR CREATIVE
CONFIDENCE. MEMBERS I'D GIVE
THEM ALL A HEARTY ROUND OF
APPLAUSE. WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
CONGRATULATIONS TO THIS YEAR'S
HONOREES AND THIS CONCLUDES OUR
OBSERVANCE OF SYNC OUT OF MY
WEEK AND THE LATINO SPIRIT
AWARDS. MEMBERS WE ARE BACK. IN
FILE ORDER AT FILE ITEM. NINETY
SIX. THIS IS H. A R. TEN FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
COVERAGE WITH IMMENSE ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION TEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME MEMBER CHOI.
THAT COULD NOT DESTROY ALL THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND A MEMBER SO I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT A TWO VERIA MINOR
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS- TO AJ ON
TEN. WHICH WERE RECOMMENDED BY
THE ASSEMBLY. MILITARY AND THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE I'M
NOT I THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY COLLEAGUES OF
ROMA- THE VENTURA COUNTY FOR
SUPPORTING AJ HONORED TEN
AUTUMN COMMITTEE AND THE HER
STAFF FOR SUGGESTING THIS-
SORRY MINA A CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU DR CHOI
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE- SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED RESOLUTION
IS OUT OF PRINT TO BACK OFF
FILE. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
GO BACK IN THE FILE. TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM. FIFTY SEVEN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN AB 127%
OF AYE MR STONE. AND THE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
TWENTY SEVEN BY CENTER KAMLAGER
AN ACCOLADE TO ARREST WARRANTS
MR STONE EMAIL THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED 2% AB ONE TWENTY SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF NOW SENATOR
KAMLAGER AND WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT ADDS TO THE LIST OF
THOSE WHO CAN. ASK FOR A AN
ARREST WARRANT FOR A POLICE
OFFICER A PROSECUTING ATTORNEY
SO INSTEAD OF A POLICE OFFICER
HAVING TO BE THE AFGHAN FOR AN
ARREST WARRANT IT WOULD ALLOW A
PUBLIC PROSECUTOR TO PERFORM
THAT FUNCTION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK- THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS GONE THROUGH
OUR PROCESS ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR COMMA GRASS HERE EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SOME. SAY NO
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
CONCERNED ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
BETTER SAID ABOUT. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF ICE
FORTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT. THE
MEASURE PASSES WE ARE MOVING TO
CONSENT CALENDAR. REMEMBER
WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATE
HEARING ON THE CORKERY THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE OH ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON AN ACT
RELATING TO RENTAL PASSENGER
VEHICLE TRANSACTIONS. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. THIS IS THE CAN CHECK
OUT OUR. THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY EIGHT.
NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. CALGARY THE REMAINING
ITEM ON CONSENT ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY
FIVE. I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED A GERMAN
TO MEMORY. AT THIS TIME I'D ASK
THAT YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME. THIS
IS ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MISTER RUBIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- DURING IN
MEMORY TODAY FOR GRACE LARA
PUGH. A CONSTITUENT OF MINE
FROM WEST COVINA FOR OVER
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS GRAYSON
SERVED AS A VOLUNTEER FOR THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY AND
ALSO AS A LEGISLATIVE
AMBASSADOR VOLUNTEER WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK. SHE DEVOTED
COUNTLESS HOURS OF HER TIME AND
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO HELP
EDUCATE PEOPLE ABOUT PREVENTION
AND EARLY DETECTION AND SUPPORT
PATIENTS SURVIVORS AND
CAREGIVERS. GRACE WAS
INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE AT USING
HER VOICE TO HELP OTHERS AND
ENSURE THAT YOUR PEOPLE HEAR
THE WORDS YOU HAVE CANCER.
GRACE WITH MY FRIEND IN A
SUPPORTER SHE ALWAYS VISITED ME
IN MY DISTRICT OFFICE TO SAY
HELLO AND ALWAYS ALWAYS HAD A
SMILE I'M GRATEFUL TO HAVE
KNOWN HER. SHE IS SURVIVED BY
HER CHILDREN BAD KATHY AND CAN.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE ADJOURNED TODAY SESSION
IN NAME MEMORY OF GRACE LARA Q.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS RUBIO.
AND MR RAMIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN OF MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST TO- THAT WE'RE JOINED
TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF JULIE
LOUISE BOGAN THE- A WELL
RESPECTED FRIEND. AND ELDER IN
A MIGHTY SPIRIT IN THE GAVIRIA
ANIL NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
JULIA PASSED AWAY MARCH TWENTY
EIGHTH AT REDLANDS COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
TWO. AND IS SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND ANDREW FOUR CHILDREN
TEN GRANDCHILDREN AND ELEVEN
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. MISS
BAGANI SERVED AS A MEMBER OF
THE GABRIELLE TONGVA TRIBAL
COUNCIL. AND NEVER STOP
TEACHING AND PROMOTING HER
LANGUAGE THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND IN PARTICULAR
THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY. HER
CAREER STARTED AS A PRESCHOOL
TEACHER. AS SHE BECAME
INTERESTED IN HER GALLERY AND A
FAMILY HISTORY. SHE BEGAN A
DEEP STUDY OF OUR CULTURE. MISS
BAGANI WAS SPURRED TO ACTION IN
PART BY THE QUESTION FROM HER
GRANDDAUGHTER. ASKING HOW IT
FELT TO BE NATIVE. M. AS BOGAN
REPLY. SOMETIMES IT FEELS
INVISIBLE. JULIA NEVER STOP
WORKING TO KEEP THE FEELING OF
INVISIBILITY FROM BECOMING
REALITY NOT JUST FOR HER BUT
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS HER DATE
COULD START AS EARLY AS FOUR AM
AND NOT UNTIL AFTER TEN PM SHE
CONTINUED TO MOVE FORWARD AND
SHARING CULTURE. SHE DEEPLY
CARED AND TAUGHT EDUCATION TO
STUDENTS AND ART SHE PRODUCED A
TONGA DICTIONARY AND MANY
RECORDED HOURS OF ZOOM WEBINARS.
MISTER BOGUTY ALSO COLLABORATED
WITH EDUCATORS TO REVISE THE
CURRICULUM TOP ABOUT CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICANS. SHE WAS AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE INDIGENOUS
EDUCATION NOW COALITION AND A
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE KEEPERS
OF INDIGENOUS WAYS AT TONGA
NONPROFIT. MISS BALDONI
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD AND
LEAVING IN A STILL IN THE MANY
OF US THROUGHOUT INDIAN COUNTRY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SHE
LEAVES BEHIND A RICH AND
ABUNDANT LEGACY THAT DEFIITELY
IS NOT INVISIBLE ANYMORE. AND
HER FAMILY INTERTRIBAL THE
COMMUNITY WHO CELEBRATE AND
CHERISH FOR LIFE. WE EXTEND OUR
CONDOLENCES TO HER HER FAMILY
AND FRIENDS AND THANK HER FOR
ALL THE WORK SHE HAS DONE TO
PROMOTE NOT ONLY THE GALLERY
AND- CULTURE BUT ALL CALIFORNIA
INDIAN CULTURE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MYSTERON US MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES OF THE
DESPERATE PRINT IN THE JOURNAL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. ANNOUNCEMENTS
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY. MAY THE FOURTH CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY MAY THE
FIFTH CHECKING SESSION THURSDAY
MAY SIXTH. YOUR SESSION IS AT
NINE AM ALL OF THE ITEMS
REMAINING WOULD PASS RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING A FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. DOCTOR
WOULD MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY MAY
THE SIXTH AT NINE AM IN THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.